gerhard schröder hat sich in der new
york times zu wladimir putin geäußert da
hat sich nicht von ihm losgesagt und er
hat dafür heftige empörung geerntet der
cdu abgeordnete marco wanderwitz nennt
schröder einen bundeskanzler der schande
ich antworte darauf last schröder in
ruhe
schröder es
sieht seine beziehung zu zu putin
zunächst mal muss ich sagen schröder ist
nicht abhängig von putin er hat sich er
hat sich nicht in unsere geschichten
verstrickt in moskau denn er ist nicht
erpressbar
er hat keine schwarzgeld geschäfte
gemacht davon bin ich fest überzeugt es
gibt auch keine heimlich aufgenommenen
videos mit frauengeschichten aus moskau
wie man sie donald trump nachgesagt hat
alles das gibt es nicht schröder
betrachtet putin als seinen persönlichen
freund und ich betone persönlichen
freund es ist der freund seines lebens
er hat nicht viele das ist der freund
seines lebens und freundschaft wirkliche
freundschaft heißt dass sie
bedingungslos ist das heißt man hält
auch dann zu einem freund wenn deren
schweren fehler macht und man kann sogar
dann zu ihm halten wenn er zum
verbrecher wird und das ist in diesem
fall offensichtlich so was ist die basis
dieser freundschaft ganz sicher kann man
nur mutmaßen ganz sicher dass beide aus
ärmlichen sozialen verhältnissen kommen
und sich sehr verwandt fühlen in der
hinsicht ganz sicher auch dass putin
gerd schröder zwei adoptivkinder besorgt
hat in moskau diese kinder hätte
schröder in seinem alter in deutschland
nicht mehr bekommen können und
schröder ist hat dafür
schwere nachteile in kauf genommen er
ist sein ruf ist erledigt in deutschland
weitgehend er ist er ist isoliert er ist
einsam
er hat viele ehrungen und auszeichnungen
aus der vergangenheit verloren
wie er da rauskommen will weiß ich nicht
dabei hat sich entschlossen
er hat sich entschlossen seinen freund
nicht zu verraten und das ist eine ich
wiederhole noch mal eine persönliche
motivation die mir sogar respekt
abnötigt obwohl putin ein verbrecher ist
aber das kann ich nachvollziehen weil
ich eine eigene erfahrung gemacht habe
die nicht so schwerwiegend ist das zu
tun zu einem freund zu halten und ihn
nicht zu verraten kostet viel kraft ich
habe diese kraft nicht gehabt als ich
meine freundschaft zu uli hoeneß
zerstört habe ich war eingeladen in eine
talkshow
in der ard
bei günther jauch als
hoeneß wegen seiner steuerhinterziehung
es ging um knapp 30 millionen zu einer
gefängnisstrafe verurteilt worden war da
wurde ich heftig mit kritischen fragen
unter druck gesetzt und ich habe dann
gesagt dass ich steuerhinterziehung in
diesem ausmaß für asozial halte das war
meine politische überzeugung aber es ist
natürlich
uli hoeness nicht gerecht geworden
er hat die sendung nicht gesehen er war
schon zu bett gegangen an diesem abend
aber seine frau hat sie gesehen und als
seine frau zu ihm gekommen ist hat sie
geweint da war mein verhältnis zu ihm
meine freundschaft zu ihm erledigt und
ich habe das immer so ist auch heute
noch als den fehler meines lebens
betrachtet
dann würde ich sagen sollten sie ohne
hoeneß anrufen und sich entschuldigen
ich finde es sehr schwierig ob malawi
herrn hoeneß und wladimir putin zu
vergleich das gilt nicht
und ich bin die erste die guard schröder
ermutigt werden weil ihm ihr putin in
den haag in haft sitzt den mal besuchen
zu gehen und ihn wenn er dort seine haft
für die kriegsverbrechen der begeht
absitzt und zu recht dort inhaftiert ist
da vorbeizugehen und wladimir putin gute
worte zu sprechen es ist aber etwas
anderes ob man kriegsverbrechen
kleinredet und verharmlost und das sehe
ich bei gerhard schröder aktuell und
dann ist gerd rüdiger nicht allein in
einer persönlichen freundschaft zu
schröder mit russland verbunden sondern
auch durchaus noch durch eigene
berufliche interessen und ja finanziell
ich kann das 100 prozent nachvollziehen
was sie sagen wenn der freund immer
hässlicher wird muss man ihn heftig
schminken damit man noch zu ihm halten
kann und schröder ist dabei bot ihnen
immer weiter zu schminken die tiefen
falten und die schwarzen ringe um die
augen zu zu schminken man hat das
gesehen als er nach mutter gefragt wurde
und dem massaker dort und gesagt hat
dass habe putin nicht angeordnet er hat
dabei den zweiten teil der wahrheit
vergessen dass putin nämlich die einheit
die das begangen hat ausgezeichnet hat
und die damit zum vorbild für die
russische armee erhoben hat das heißt
man sieht daran wie jemand in
schwierigkeiten gerät auch in
glaubwürdigkeitsprobleme wenn er zu
einem freund steht er tut es aber ich
rede jetzt nur von der individuellen
seite von schröder ich rede nicht von
der politischen und ich würde wenn ich
das noch sagen darf sie haben völlig
recht was die funktionen angeht seine
position in der in der russischen kriegs
in der russischen energiewirtschaft da
sollte man ihm den verrat abnehmen man
sollte ihm wie überhaupt das kann man
als allgemeines gesetz machen man sollte
deutschen staatsbürgern verbieten als
sanktion
führungspositionen in russischen
staatsunternehmen zu übernehmen dann
könnte er das nicht mehr warum tut man
das nicht und fordert inständig auf er
möchte auf die positionen verzichten man
kann es ihm einfach verbieten das ist
keine besonderen einschränkung das recht
vielleicht wäre vielleicht doch du
kannst dann allgemeines gesetz machen es
werden ja auch alle möglichen leute
unter unter sanktionen gestellt viele
leute und dass sanktionen gestellt
natürlich kann man deutschen verbieten
in der russischen energiewirtschaft
führungspositionen zu übernehmen da
musst du nicht im kopf ich würde das
ist einfach weil andere sanktionen sind
auch als stimmungssänger ein anwalt jan
tisch ich wollte aussagen harry man
würde ihm möglich über einen gefallen
tun weil man die entscheidung abnimmt er
kann gar nicht mehr da sitzen dann ist
die sache erledigt dann gibt es nur noch
eine freundschaft seite an der
geschichte also ich glaube das mag ja
sein dass schröder der an den freund
putin hat aber der putin ist nicht der
freund vom schröder ja das ist es nicht
er nutzt ihn seit er kannst ist oder war
aus für seine zwecke sei es dort
trotzdem zwei ist ohne schröder ist in
dieser form nicht möglich und er benutzt
ihn nicht mehr und nicht weniger unserem
mitleid bitte herrn schröder ist da auch
eher geringer ausgeprägt denke auch mit
uli höchsten ist kann man das überhaupt
nicht vergleichen er ist ein verbrecher
und ich erwarte wenn er jetzt schon
freund ist ja sehen dass klar sagt dass
die freundschaft eigentlich zerstört ist
durch worden durch ihn und ich verstehe
solche interviews wie new york times
überhaupt nicht nur alles beschönigt
alles noch gerade richtig für ihn ja das
ist doch ein freundschaftsdienst eine
echte freundschaft hätte sagen müssen
das war zu viel das ist unerträglich
unsere freundschaft ist zerstört wo soll
denn da die dance gehen sie mal davon
aus dass er ihm das gesagt hat jetzt mal
davon aus ja gehen sie mal davon aus
dass er das in der schärfe öffentlich
nicht sagen will der ist ja nicht blöd
da ist immer noch sozialdemokrat er war
es ein ganzes leben lang ich setze mich
dann gegen ein bisschen dagegen zur wehr
dass sie mir ein bisschen alle beide
unterstellen ich würde uli hoeneß mit
herrn putin vergleichen das tue ich
nicht ich rede nur davon was es bedeutet
wenn man einen freund fallen lässt oder
verrät was das individuell bedeutet das
hat mich sehr lange gequält und ich
glaube auch schröder wird das lange
quälen wenn er das tun würde das die
freundschaft einseitig ist jedenfalls
nicht ausgewogen das ist auch mein
eindruck denn als schröder in moskau war
musste auch an dem sechs meter tisch
platz nehmen also der der putin hat die
nicht anders behandelt wie andere
besucher und er hat den mit leeren
händen wieder weggeschickt hat nichts
mitgebracht nicht mal einen humanitären
korridor für mario pohl oder irgendetwas
24 stunden feuerpause nichts hat er
mitgebracht
wenn wir heute bilder sehen wie die
beiden sich begegnet in den vergangenen
jahren dann sehen wir immer dass
schröder bot aber nicht umgekehrt also
da ist schon was wahres dran das ändert
aber nichts daran die subjektive seite
bei schröder ist die dass er mit dem man
befreundet ist also lasst ihn in ruhe er
wird diese freundschaft nicht aufgeben
und er hat was die spd angeht weil es ja
jetzt alle möglichen papas ranzen vision
sich die schuhe an ihm ab der hat für
die spd sehr viel getan übrigens auch
für deutschland und diese freundschaft
wenn man ihm die posten abnimmt wofür
ich bin diese freundschaft sollte man
ihm lassen
also ich finde bei allem respekt auch
für freundschaften und
männerfreundschaften und dass wir das
natürlich in persönlichen definieren
müssen gerhard schröder ist halt immer
auch nur mehr als privatperson er ist
ehemaliger bundeskanzler dieses landes
und damit ein stück weit auch
repräsentant dieses landes und ich finde
da kann man es auch nicht einfach abtun
und sagen na ja gut der ist jetzt halt
lobbyist oder irgendeine persönliche
verbindung sondern ich finde dieses
interview ist eigentlich an zynismus
kaum zu überbieten sich dann ablichten
zu lassen in der wohnung mit dem großen
porträt wo andere gerade das haus
verlieren und die eigenen vier wände
verlieren aufgrund des krieges und dann
noch zu sagen mea culpa ist nicht mein
ding also ich übersetzte so ein bisschen
naja ihr könnt mich irgendwie mal ne ich
finde ganz ehrlich das ist auch als
repräsentant dieses landes ist im
entsprechen muss ich nicht mehr als cdu
politikern antworten ich würde mir
wünschen dass angela merkel mal in ihrem
wohnzimmer fotografiert wird oder in
ihrem büro und dass sie mal ein paar
sätze sagt was sie für putin gesagt hat
sie wartet getan hat sie waren für putin
wichtiger als schröder schröder war
nicht mehr kanzler als nord stream 2
gebaut worden ist und wer die fahrt land
durchgesetzt hat war angela merkel und
wer verhindert hat dass die ukraine in
die nato kommt war angela merkel und
wenn man da zurück schaut auf die jahre
ihrer kanzlerschaft muss man sagen sie
hat in der hinsicht viel falsch gemacht
da heute ja alle gelernt haben möchte
ich gern mal wissen hat angela merkel
auch gelernt das möchte ich gern mal
sehen setzen sie man ihren einfluss ein
dass sie sich mal den nächster zeit
äußert zu dem was sie getan hat niemand
sagt dass die energiepolitik in den
letzten jahren ohne fehler ist ganz klar
wir müssen erkennen dass fehler gemacht
worden sind aber ich finde das recht
fertig der trotzdem auf der anderen
seite so ein verhalten eines ehemaligen
bundeskanzler sich also was rechtfertigt
das verhalten von frau merkel sie solle
sich doch mal selbst rechtfertigen was
hat sie dazu gebracht der aufnahme der
ukraine in die nato im jahr 2008 nicht
zuzustimmen die zu verhindern denn 2014
hat dann die okkupation der krim gegeben
dann hat es den als das einzige
russischer truppen in der ost ukraine
gegeben und jetzt eben diesen krieg
alles das hätte es nicht gegeben wenn
die ukraine in der nato wäre da kann man
sagen heute ist man immer schlauer das
stimmt auch das muss man ab streichen
weil seinen heutigen positionen aber ich
möchte ich wiederhole mal ich möchte
wenn sie sagen das ist zynisch was herr
schröder sagt ich möchte mal wissen wie
frau merkel argumentiert verdammt noch
mal die frau hat neun angestellte in
ihrem büro sie kriegt eine fette pension
und sie kann sich mal öffentlich äußern
zu solchen diskussionen oder nicht also
zum einen noch mal es sind fehler
gemacht worden stichwort nato-beitritt
2008 das würde man aus heutiger sicht
sicherlich anders entscheiden aber das
rechtfertigt nicht für das was glaube
ich gerhard schröder momentan macht und
wie er sich äußert also dann lieber gar
nicht äußern als sich so zu äußern viele
ein kurzem organischer können so zu
äußern wie er das an der stelle momentan
tut bei den übrigen noch ein stichwort
nord stream 1 wurde unter gerhard
schröder beschlossen